hey just CU someone's from the death
start doesn't make them just someone's
from the death start find him call me
back like there's something wrong find
him call
name find him call me back
[Music]
like
y just like I'll take
[Music]
your
[Applause]
[Music]
h
[Applause]
[Music]
bu remember none of this is possible
without you you join the fight and sign
up for mug club today at
louderwithcrowder.com mugclub for $89
annually join the fight at
louderwithcrowder.com mug club
[Music]
[Applause]
today what I
know
[Music]
did someone else swallow it's not like
my honeymoon stop
it I haven't introduced you yet kill his
Mike until I introduce him I should have
let that coffee spill on him this
morning I should have let that coffee
spill on him opportunity we have a lot
to get to here today I'll tell you about
the you know I'm the problem is I give
too much I care too much you do yes uh I
wasn't my own personal hell it was a
moral quandry this morning but here's a
quick rundown as to what we'll be
getting into Nikki Haley works for China
you know that
but we have an update for you who is
hero 121 we did that piece yesterday is
it related to rape.is it.co dosu they
keep changing it they changed it yeah
and I know some people saying well hold
on a second there's some stuff there
might be some information missing
absolutely absolutely we have received a
letter from a lawyer Gerald you have to
jump in if at any point I say gets me in
trouble uh and the problem here is we
held some things back because we knew
that there were other Mis truths if
that's a word and we have the receipts
today the plot thickens and it's
concerning so that man right there he's
the one who taught us how to do this and
you hold back some of your strongest
cards so uh we have that here today and
we appreciate your support we'll talk
about the New Hampshire Prim Mary this
guy uh yel Harari you know he his his
Ted Talk at the WF went viral he's also
gay is he well you know one could guess
his accent doesn't make any sense it's
like half Persian maybe German and a lot
of homosexual it's just all squirrel in
the one and then on we have some car
Lake audio regarding bribery not her
someone else by the way so we'll have
her on the show tomorrow my question for
you what was your biggest takeaway from
uh well the primary yesterday and then
yesterday's story with uh hero 121 uh I
have to stay by the book when we talk
about that look when when your lawyers
go hey look at me look at
me you stick to this exact wording and
you'll be right don't get cute with it
that's what we have to do today so CEO
Captain Morgan how are you sir I'm doing
well and then right before going live
there was a new development that just
took place it was and we we'll tell
everybody about that I'm doing great
like
yes indeed we'll give you some updates
about some of the behind the scenes
obviously we can't tell everybody
everything but it's uh it is very
interesting information how are you
doing well I have a flu I have a flu
it's been going it's been just tearing
through this entire so worse than Co yes
worse than significantly worse than Co
okay significantly uh more likely to die
from it than Co yes so uh and when you
hear this may dump that you know who it
is in third chair May 11th at the count
bayy Center for the Arts in Red Bank New
Jersey go see the the funniest man alive
the funniest standup comedian I say
working today uh and of course you can
watch him on mug Club Nick dip.com for
all his dates Nick depalo how are you
hey great to be here why does it feel
like I'm going to get shot be doing this
show well you're fine because you're not
car or something Savannah yeah you
shouldn't have upgraded at Hertz to the
convertible in 20° it's a nice day put
down the Rope I say put to me in
Dallas want to go for a drive downtown
Nick back and to the
left
um and we have a special by the way of
yours going up on Friday a special this
and it's by the it's not just a standup
special but this it's more of a tribute
his what I believe are his best bits and
some of his interviews that you've seen
on shows like tough crowd with Colin
Quinn uh where early early on you could
watch him and say oh oh oh yeah that guy
is going to be
cancel ex we knew from the begin let me
just say this this is one of the first
times that we've done this we're
actually giving Early Access Thursday to
mug Club to be able to see that so as a
benefit of being in mug Club Thursday
Early Access you'll get it and then
Friday it'll go out on the and seriously
I can't thank you guys enough um for
doing that because that's real marketing
which I'm too lazy to do well eventually
eventually you'll thank us enough that's
why we have a green
room wait I I don't get it hey by the
way if at any point you if at any point
you see this during the program think
confessional that means head on over to
rumble from YouTube YouTube I'm deaf my
ears are all blocked so or anything else
yeah just head on over to rumble anyway
stop watching on YouTube it's stupid
it's just let's come on if nothing else
at this point get your ass off YouTube
before anything else we'll talk about
New Hampshire later uh I just want to
keep running this clip because this is a
disqualifier uh Nikki Haley deserves to
be nowhere near that Podium here's why I
told them that if they would do this
that South Carolina would wrap their
arms around and take care of them I now
officially work for you there is nothing
that you can need that we won't make
sure that we deliver that clip needs to
be on a loop like a morphine drip yes
works for China
that stop
go not not today but but I'm tracking
with you Mel Gibson head look that to me
is just as bad as smoking crack with
underage prostitutes the I work for you
China especially considering what we
know about them buying up American land
them wanting to subvert Western culture
that needs to be shared every I mean you
know what I'm going to make it a polic
I'm going to share I'm going to fit that
into the show somehow every day between
now and South Carolina which will result
in domestic battery she's going to lose
South Carolina she's going to get beaten
in her home state de ah it'll be like a
lifetime film blue star Airline wasn't
that in Wall Street blue star was yes
yes yes I didn't hear the word because
I'm half
dead heard heard Wall Street and
canel well you know Nick some of us
don't judge the by size of his wallet
so everyone quotes the greed is good
that's the line of the movie I love the
the elevator scene yes elevator with
Martin Sheen before he he also was he
yell I I like greed is good better I'm
just saying I'm a greed is that's cuz
you're a prick
now okay a lot to get to should I tell
I'll tell the story M about how Nick
depalo almost spilled coffee all over
himself and I I didn't need to stop it
he saved his life I saved his life I
saved his life I think you're
exaggerating that but well you know look
you're at that point I don't know not
like I was in a tu that point where
you're getting to the age where you know
any type of trauma might be like ah
you're true yeah walking around with a
I'm walking around with scrambled eggs
in my mustache I'm I'm worried you're
like an iguana that if I scare you
you'll fall out of a
tree all right delicious so go here's
this guy uh this has been making the
rounds again okay this W uh this WF wait
yes we're looking I was about to say WCW
yeah wrestling which technically is n
new world order but
uh this is making the rounds again so
this is not a new clip but because the
WF WR work we're kind of at that it's
the worst time of the year um this has
captured people's attention and I think
it shows the fundamental
difference between conservatism and
leftism progress uh progressivism and um
this idea of international governments
this idea of globalism it's very rare
that you get something that is so so
perfectly encapsulating of what is wrong
with the left I like borders I want the
United States to be different from the
rest of the world I do not this when
people see uh the folks holding hands We
are the world I go yeah but there are
slave owners in that chain of people I
don't want to be with the rest of them I
love having something that divides us
that shows that we're different that
shows why we left the world's greatest
superpower one century to become the
world's only superpower The Next Century
and we're the only to do it ever and to
do it and go into other nations which I
don't necessarily believe in because I'm
not interventionist go into other
nations and help them rebuild and often
ask for nothing more than the land in
which to bury the dead who tried to help
them now I'm talking about the people
fighting not the people with pencils at
desks in the three-letter agencies at
home so I like borders I like the United
States being I know it sounds great hey
we're all human beings nope we're not
genas Khan was a human being so was
Stalin so was was Hitler
himler and George you know George
Washington hey one of these things is
not like the other we're not all human
beings you can put Pelosi right in there
she'd be right she'd be right right
above Hitler as far as evil but probably
below mangala and even then it's a
tossup it's a tossup the betting lines
would be even Sports bet you know
so now in the resurface Ted Talk uh this
transhumanist Yuval Harari is uh he
talks here about how hum and Nations and
he believes this he says a quiet part
out loud have no inherent and I want to
be clear here there's a very big
difference between human rights natural
rights and civil rights but he says you
have no rights at all many maybe most
legal systems are based on this idea
this belief in human rights but human
rights are just like heaven and like God
it's just a fictional story that we've
invented and spread around it may be a
very nice story it may be a very
attractive story we want to believe it
but it's just a story pause we'll go
back to it
[Music]
heyer uh did just and I want to go back
to some of his other points look here's
the point this guy has the ear of the
leaders right of the world this wef guy
when he says they are just fiction
fictional God fiction let's let's go
with that let's say all right it's all
fiction secular humanism is still really
dumb let me explain to you think it's a
good thing that our founding fathers
here believe in this fictional God
because they believed in natural rights
what does that mean natural human rights
are based in natural rights based in
natural law what that means is you are
born with inalienable rights that
government does not serve to Grant they
simply serve to protect why because you
were born with them because there's a
God who created you let me read you a
couple of quotes and show you why this
is as evil as it gets uh let's just
start with a declaration of independence
we hold these truths to be self-evident
that all men are created equal that they
were endowed by their creator with
certain unalienable rights that among
these are life liberty and the pursuit
of happiness that whenever any form of
government becomes destructive of these
ends that's so important because a
homosexual man like him benefits from
these same fictional rights
the government becomes destructive of
these ends it is the right of the people
to alter or to abolish it and to
Institute new government laying its
foundation on such principles and
organizing its powers in such form as to
them shall seem most likely to affect
their safety and happiness here's the
thing without human rights without
natural law there can be no civil rights
there can be no queers getting married
just to be clear there can be no
abolition of slavery you have to
understand that if you're simply
starting from the standpoint of civil
rights different between human right and
a civil right human right is a birth
right it's it's founded a natural law
Civil Right is a right that a government
or a state or a society grants and
recognizes that's why you have stupid
rights for example I believe in Germany
they say it's a it's a right to have the
internet okay I think that's dumb but
you can do that Germany because you know
you screwed up twice now the rest of the
world protects you so this is one of
those foundational differences civil
rights human rights but there can be no
civil rights without the understanding
of Human Rights so the abolition of
slavery hey if it's just a civil right
the government can choose to Grant it or
not no no it was abolished because
people said that's a violation of
fundamental human rights or as this man
would refer to them fictional let me
read you something from MLK here on
specifically natural law which is the
basis of these fictional rights he says
I'll read it like him who cares at this
point one may well ask how can you
Advocate breaking some laws and obeying
others the answer lies in the fact that
there are two types of laws just and
unjust I would be the first to Advocate
obeying just laws one has not only a
legal but a moral responsibility to obey
just laws conversely one has a moral
responsibility to disobey unjust laws I
would agree with St Augustine that a
quote unjust law is no law at all in
other words and this is something that's
foundational to Christians hey sure you
follow the law of the land unless it
violates fictional God's law let's start
with it being fictional that's still the
basis of the rights you follow the law
unless the law says you can own another
human being hold on a second that's a
violation of a natural right endowed to
us in alienable by our creator this is
super important even if you're an
atheist even if you're an agnostic you
benefit from those rights you benefit
from that silly Flying Spaghetti Monster
and every single statement that this man
goes on to make would justify and it has
been used as the philosophy to justify
every great viol violation of Human
Rights and atrocities including genocide
that we have seen throughout history so
let's continue to listen to this trans
humanist
prick not a reality it is not a
biological reality just as jellyfish and
woodpeckers and ostriches have no rights
Homo sapiens have no rights also oh boy
take a human cut him open look inside
you find their blood and you find the
heart and lungs and kidneys there any
rights the only place pause not if it's
a woman but here's the
thing that you cut open the human which
I don't I can't figure out this accent I
mean I know it's it sounds like an evil
sounds like a bond villain yeah but if
you cut the human open it's funny your
worldview is exactly what allowed for
just that to happen you guys ever heard
of what happened during World War II the
infamous uh there was Unit 731 from
Japan they cut people open just to see
how long would take until they died they
would cut people apart limb by limb they
would they would perform torture on
pregnant women just just to see what
would happen see see what kind of
diseases would kill people because you
can cut someone open who has no rights
if you don't believe in evil go look up
Unit 731 your worldview allowed exactly
that human beings being cut open because
they have no rights other than to serve
what right you enjoy and nobody nobody
said that they were like I I feel what
am I watching Zoolander where it's like
where are the files when he throws the
computer down and it breaks open he
doesn't what do you expect to find
inside of people how is this an
intellectual point that somebody feels
confident to make at a TED talk if you
cut US Open you don't find rights in
there it it doesn't make any sense you
don't understand J you also don't find
medoran but what if you do you don't
find yeah you know what find an atom
dumbass there's a lot just because you
can't see it doesn't mean that it
doesn't exist and by the way there's
also meta there's also meta rights that
we're talking about people are human
beings are Spiritual Beings by the way I
bet you he does tantric yoga or some
so he probably fancies himself
spiritual just not when it comes to
accountability you know because he
doesn't want to ad Med has AIDS yes Nick
pantri yoga he's playing twister with
some Cub
Scouts
naked let me ask you about Unit 731 one
of my favorite sitcoms
uh me Jesus Monday Tuesday amputees a
ask did they do it before the Germans
did that type of stuff oh the Chinese
and the Japanese way ahead of time oh
they were so but World War II you know
it happened during World War II but
there's a lot and ger yeah theyve well
they've and what's so weird about that
is they also again if you don't believe
in fundamental human rights the Japanese
to the Chinese remember they also
believed that they were the superior
race so the Aryan said were the superior
race to rule the world but so did the
Japanese and that's a really awkward
tiebreaker if they
won who's the Nazis would have D I guess
it's just us two so well if you go by
the Little League World Series of
Japanese yes that's true but if you go
by who can reach the top shelf I think
we're we're 10
and0 Gerald looks like kind of an Arian
guy oh he is he's one of us we use him
for propaganda but we don't have rights
for his pictures single party consent
what father
hler all right let me see is there
anything else wel back Nick yeah no this
is It's just think and this guy well I
guess there's more of the clip let's
watch the rest of the clip but I
think you find rights is in the
fictional stories that humans have
invented and spread around that's you
and HIV and the same thing is also true
in the political field States and
nations are also like human rights and
like God and like heaven they too of are
just stories a mountain is a reality you
can see it you can touch it smell it the
name of or the United States they are
just stories very powerful stories
stories we might want to believe very
much but still they are just stories
yeah like when he told you he was 18 the
United States you cannot like a g smell
it looks like customer service yes he's
very obsessed with touching and smelling
can I order a Pelon you jeuk you can
touch it you can smell it I don't
believe in things I can't touch smell or
suck count clockwise swirl soy boy
perhaps hook my point is at some point a
remote control is going in an orifice
you can smell it you can touch it it's
real what's amazing is he's talking
about this is all just uh stories
written by but he's Jewish they wrote
the original story well don't don't
paint us always the same brush unless
it's a tickly brush in which
case my body Is a
Wonderland he's a
home let me ask you this look why do you
think the the world economic form is so
anti-human everything about them is
anti-human the environmentalism hey
basically you solve that problem just
killing people the problems with the
global economies just kill people's Free
Will and ability to own anything hey the
idea of f borders foundational human
rights no hold on a second that's just
something that we need to do away with
so we can be internationalist if these
people have their these people have
their finger on the proverbial button
and have control over what happens
across the this is going to be an evil
evil place it's not just about globalism
and gay frogs just listen to what they
say it's evil everything that you want
everything that you care about look
knowledge I'm yes I'm sounding the alarm
Bell here do you like owning property
they don't want you to be able to own
property do you enjoy privacy rights
they don't want you to have privacy
rights do you want to be able to pick
what it is that you drive they don't
want you to be able to pick what it is
that you drive do you want to be able to
pick what it is that you eat they don't
want you to be able to pick what you eat
do you want to be able to pick where
your kids go to school they don't want
you to be allowed to choose where your
kids go to school through International
mandate with people who live in
countries where you've never been and
you've never elected that's why it's
evil that's why I say just and you know
just the WF sorry okay there you go
I'm sorry okay join mug club by the way
you hit that button right there and you
join mug club and you get to continue
get Nicko special I just I you know look
it's wrong to
hate what's surprising about this guy he
was drafted by the Chicago Bears in the
second round in 2015 is a tackling gummy
no as an actual he was a strong safety
he's doesn't look like he has that type
of body serious Clark fact checko they
wanted me for the purple people
eaters though when in Rome a purple
helmet Warrior sometimes is tasty
so green B Packers okay I'm kidding it's
always
tasty I think this hor is dead we've
beaten it enough oh my God we stoed on
its head put it in somebody's bed next
yeah there you go all right hey by the
way Nick depalo huge fan of Godfather 3
that's his new nickname that is not that
what do you why do you keep saying
that's horrible I I actually broke my TV
watching
that many times like Elvis I knew it
wasn't a it wasn't a good movie when
Nathan Lane was playing Michael corot
yeah oh I don't know just kill him you
betrayed
me
let me just say this that was The
Godfather cage yeah uh all right hey
there's a lot that has happened uh since
yesterday with uh you know we brought
you the story of I want to make sure
it's hero 121 hero1 121 and that
includes some uh notices from lawyers uh
of course and when you're dealing with
the most powerful companies in the world
uh you know look we all do our due
diligence but of course we have reason
to be concerned so
today we fire back again it's time for
an update on the Club undercover
[Music]
story so just to be clear I'm going to
run a clip and if you saw the whole
installment yesterday uh it may feel
like it's uh you know remedial for you
but a lot of people didn't let me first
set this up before ever releasing that
story okay we reached out to uh Miss
Geller's lawyer uh Jack Balman okay and
Gerald do you want to you want to
explain that before we run a CP to we
actually sent the piece to him in that
and and asked several questions in that
communication to the lawyer uh and our
team was reaching out basically saying
like hey last last chance to give us
some evidence here or to provide some of
the stuff that you said that you would
provide to us um and we'll get into some
of the responses we got from him earlier
that necessitated this followup yes in
our minds we just wanted to to do all of
our due diligence and uh the responses
that we got were really more of the same
more misrepresentation
of the facts alarming alarmingly so and
we knew so before releasing the piece
and decided that we were going to
release the piece as is uh so that we
could see exactly what would transpire
and there have been some developments
that again alarming and if we can all
find Common Ground hey child sex
trafficking is obviously as evil as it
gets and if you know something this is
where if you know something you need to
say something so at the very least that
is what we are dealing with and at worst
were you about to say something else
yeah I was just going to say too because
we we were making the claim that this
email is connected and this video does
that this email address yes we didn't
say any further activity we even
included a disclaimer at the bottom of
the video no no further activity there
was no evidence of that trying to give
them every opportunity to respond with
something and what we got just and
perhaps assist that's the important
thing perhaps assist because there is no
doubt that there are people who are
involved with there's no doubt that
there are people who are helping
facilitate or taking part in sexual
exploitation of minors there's no doubt
about that just to be clear yeah so hey
let's let's work together with this the
responses make it seem uh as though uh
some folks not the folks are more
interested in covering their ass than
actually uh getting these criminals off
of I don't want to say off the streets
off the planet if I may be so bold so
let me just update you this video
connected the uh apparent email of Black
Rock you all know about Black Rock and
I'm sure they'll be thrilled to know
what's going on at WF right now uh the
Black Rock managing uh director sorry
Abigail Geller okay we released this
piece that connected this email uh to a
child exploitation site known as rapy
dosu if you missed it here's a recap
because the developments are severe I
telling you the allegation that my
client has anything to do with a child
exploitation or rapy doxu is false and
defamatory and I am advising you in the
strongest possible term not
to publish such a
thing on May 11th 2023 the Department of
Justice issued a press release regarding
four men who were sentenced for engaging
in a child exploitation Enterprise the
child exploitation Enterprise being
rape. suu an open web platform operated
by the late convicted felon Nathan lson
members of this website would share
media of pedophilia child rape and even
tried to arrange in-person meetups
in 2023 cyber security professional Ryan
Montgomery went public and discussed how
he obtained user data from Nathan
larsson's Network the data obtained by
Montgomery revealed over 7,000 email
addresses of individuals who became
members of
rape. it's important to note that the
application process contained questions
such as if a man wants to rape his
three-year-old daughter up every hole
while she's crying and screaming do you
have a problem with that to be clear the
only way for these thousands of users to
have their email show up in the database
they or someone who breached their email
account had to answer this question the
email address
h121 mail.com connected to the username
Jackie 222 it is worth noting that when
investigating email addresses they often
connect to multiple individuals however
this email address repeatedly linked
back to the one name more than 10
identity verification Services strongly
suggest that this email is only
associated with one possible name Black
Rock managing director Abigail gold
Geller to further corroborate our
research we decided to work with a
private investigator to see if they
would come up with a different
conclusion using Delo a program that
licensed private investigators use for
their investigations our private
investigator obtained this comprehensive
report which contains a wealth of
information regarding an Abigail s gold
which appears corroborated by these
other background checks including the
fact that hero1 121 mail.com was
allegedly an email of Abigail gold this
private investigator was even able to
take it a step further using delv Point
showing the addresses the email was used
at from these findings it shows hero1
121 mail.com was used two separate times
by a person named Abigail gold as well
as gold Abigail at a property she owns
in New York City lending more
credibility that this could be Abigail's
email and she was the one using it
unfortunately the report does not
indicate when she used this email and
for what purpose what all 11 of these
background checks strongly suggest is
hero1 121 mail.com doeses in fact belong
to an Abigail gold Geller I have this
tip that uh is claiming that your email
is associated with this rapy website and
I'm just trying to figure out like what
if this is bogus tip or can I give you a
call right back call you right back okay
can I call you right back yeah sure
Abigail Geller's lawyer Jack Bowman
founder and managing partner of jfb
legal had this to say regarding the
allegations It's hero1 121 mail.com okay
that is not her email address it has
never been her email address the
allegation that that is any way
associated with her is absolutely false
I telling
you the allegation that my client has
anything to do with a child
exploitation or
.xu is false and defamatory and I am
advising in the strongest possible terms
not
to publish such a thing help me here how
can you say that's clearly not her email
address though how do you know that you
just found out what the email address is
right you could go register for that
email address today on mail.com it is
not her email address and even more
concerning who signed up for this very
specific email address on this obscure
email service provider following the end
of the phone call on the morning of
September 28th 2023 before Bowman sent
the letter to us that same evening
Bowman himself admitted that you can go
on today and sign up for that email
address our team has since reached out
to the Department of Justice's eastern
district in Virginia the same office
that sentenced the four men for engaging
in the child exploitation Enterprise
R.S we provided both the username Jackie
222 and the email hero1 121 mail.com to
better assist their ongoing
investigation
all right so as we said we we heard from
the uh lawyer in question Jack Balman
mhm it's a nice name though Esquire I
guess is that what you call attorneys I
think so yeah okay and there were some
claims made by the way for
reference that man wrote the book Andrew
Breitbart I was there uh when the first
Acorn story dropped and he knew EXA he
said look you always you always hold a
little bit back always make sure you you
let them continue down the path as to
remove all doubts so let's go through
some of the claims that this lawyer has
made uh in refuting the piece here's a
claim okay he claimed that the email
hero1 121 mail.com has no association
with Abigail Gill let me read you the
exact quote as we also stated repeatedly
to lwc and your Affiliates Miss Geller
unequivocally denies ever using or
having any connection to the hero1 121
mail.com email address so that's a
pretty clear claim
truth 11 background checks from this
team here repeatedly came back to the
same person including by the way an
independent report from a private
investigator and in each one of these it
came back to one person to one person
which is unusual now you can say there's
a hacking job that's not the claim the
lawyer has made we have also we have
stated repeatedly Miss Geller
unequivocally denied is ever using or
having any connection to the hero1 121
mail.com email address 11 background
checks independent report private
investigator about that being associated
with this there is no doubt yeah that is
that is incorrect to be clear doesn't
give you the entire picture and by the
way we may have some more information
that we're holding back doesn't give you
the whole picture we're only going to
let you know exactly what it is that we
can prove right now 11 background checks
that's not true Mr Balman yeah and and
that was the question in the beginning
why tell us that from the very beginning
back in I believe September when that
phone call was recorded that that email
address has never been associated with
her even though the private ey
investigation report that came back from
Delo which is above and beyond just an
open search right right um came back
with that and it it showed a ping off of
her address which we included in the
video right like we accessing that email
again I want to be very clear I'm not
saying accessing the site using the site
doing anything with the site it's the
email right why deny any association
with well else could he
say he he could say that email has never
been used to access a site somebody else
somebody else but he didn't he said no
association whatsoever which brings us
by the way to another claim that he
makes here's the claim that there were
dozens of individuals who were
associated with that email address let's
read his exact quote by the way all
references available at ler.com I
previously advised L withth crer that
the hero 121 mail.com address was
associated with numerous individuals
other than Miss Geller we have confirmed
this to be the case through a simple
search at people.com pipl.com which is a
paid service a paid service here's the
truth we here in M Club undercover
conducted an identical people search
which again directly connects
k121 mail.com to Abigail gold Geller
here's a
clip there you
go while is this happening I'll read I
I'll read this to you we have confirmed
this to be the case through a simple
search at people.com that it is not
associated with
her this email is not associated with
Abigail gold Geller simply run a
people.com search you can do it yourself
so now we've gone through two she's
never had any association with that
address whatsoever 11 background checks
including independent report from the
most legitimate investigators who you
could hire to do so and now there are
dozens of other individuals that just
run this search we ran the search okay
back to only her only her by the way and
we we redacted a lot of that information
below the information that it was her it
was her it was the age and it was the
location yes so to remove all of the
doubt that they were trying to sew in
that response and again being very
careful to only present exactly what it
is that we can prove Beyond any doubt
right now here's another claim that was
made they said uh or this man said that
redacted data actually cuz we redacted
some some portions there would show uh
IP address
that would exonerate Miss Geller now the
concern here I just want to be very
clear is the very
clear factual misstatements there is no
doubt that these statements made by the
lawyer are
false now there could be other
information that may be relevant these
statements made definitively are
entirely false the why matters because
guess what you you watching you don't
get the benefit of
why you get cuffs so here's from Mr
Balman
this shot appears to blur out other
relevant and important information which
may include the IP addresses or other
identifiers associated with hero1 121
mail.com when it registered on the rapy
website if you choose not to provide
this information despite our
representation that we believe it will
definitively sorry def yes definitively
confirm Miss Geller had nothing to do
with the email address or website okay
so you know it gets into the realm of
threat M which is cute um definitively
confirm
had nothing to do with the email address
or website let me just be really clear
here's the
truth uh the Hacked SQL database right
from the rape. suu we it did not include
IP addresses right so that's what we
showed a originally that's what we
showed originally and and here here let
me just highlight this and this is the
portion we've unredacted some of it so
that you can see we've unredacted
information that surrounds this it's it
doesn't include IP addresses doesn't
include IP address the 160 numbers there
seem to be some kind of an identifier
that's linked to specific individuals
but not an IP address it's not the same
let me be really clear what this is he's
going hey hey you know what you redacted
hey just so everyone will question the
messenger what's redacted why don't you
unredacted show the IP addresses the
reason they do that is because they know
that you're redacting information to
protect the identity of the innocent on
redact okay there you go it has nothing
to do with IP addresses and and they're
trying to say that we are lying and that
we're covering things up no we said that
this email address existed on this
website 100% true we said that this
email address according to 11 background
checks is associated with your client
100% true all along the way here you
have said that that's false let me be
real yeah the reason that they and they
did this with Andrew Breitbart too they
said well why don't you release the
whole unedited footage to imply that
you're a liar when he would do that the
media had moved on let me make something
really clear here you guys don't
remember the Anthony Weiner a lot of you
don't the Anthony Weiner Scandal the
only reason that that became a scandal
they were prepared to ruin Andrew
breitbart's name and say that he had
hacked Anthony Weiner's private at
Twitter and that these pictures were
fabricated I remember Alec Alec Baldin
saying there's a whiff D Breitbart here
until Andrew Breitbart took Anthony
Weiner's Podium that day live when he
was about to go out there deny all the
allegations and blame Andrew and
confirmed that he had what he had if he
hadn't done that his name probably would
have never been fully restored right
because they had been going after him
for a very long time when they say hey
unredacted well here's also a lawyer
trick if you unredacted and includes
something that May reveal identity of a
third party who is innocent that's
actually a problem they simply want to
ensure that everyone questions your
legitimacy this is what they do to
everybody it's what they're doing with
indicting Donald Trump it's what they do
when they remove your accounts from
social media let me go really quickly
again just so you understand these
claims because we have an update here so
uh the claim is actually that email has
nothing to do it's never been Affiliated
whatsoever uh with Miss Geller 11
background checks say absolutely it is
true including private investigator then
there are dozens of people actually why
don't you show who've been associated
with that email run this search we ran
the search that's not true and then hey
you know what the redacted portion would
completely exonerate my client because
you're covering up the IP address hoping
that of course we don't want to reveal
some of the private information guess
what there's no IP address those three
claims are false does it mean that we
can prove everything no we can just
prove that those statements are false
and we want to know why hey if you
actually believe it help us find the
person because someone's using this
account
someone is out there taking part in the
exploitation of children can't we all be
on the same page and they have not
worked along with us any it's always
been stonewalling and misstatements yeah
and that's the problem that we're
dealing with you think that it's this
idea of look when people try and say oh
crazy Pizza gate they try and pick one
example Pizza gate that no one really
made a thing about or queueing on with
extremists so that you don't remember
wait a second Epstein actually had
pedophile Island that happened yeah that
happened and the guy killed himself in a
way that he couldn't have killed himself
period is not physically possible so
they pull out something crazy because
they want you to feel crazy you're not
you're not there are evil people in
power who do evil things and then there
are people who are complicit because
they do nothing to stop those evil
people as to where we are right now
here some of it remains to be seen now
an update here today just before we
found out just this morning during the
countdown to this show where you guys
listen to Pogo and have a good time
the lawyer here Abigail Geller's lawyer
again executive of black rock this
lawyer Jack Balman completely privatized
his
website so sometime between receiving
our request for
comment and them responding uh also
Geller removed LinkedIn
Instagram so Geller has removed this
information by the way just to be clear
that doesn't mean guilt no of course
it's just odd that it happened I don't
want to say it's just odd there
obviously are some developments there
right now before the moment we went live
to now lawyer s side is private her
information's gone following the three
misstatements that we just corrected for
you comment below hit the like button if
you want us to keep keep sha keep uh
running down people say cold Trails out
other I don't think so I don't think so
someone has to do it I'm shouldn't be
the comic it's me Gerald Morgan Nick
doollo in this room right now and then
we have an entire investigative unit out
there no one's going to do anything
about this you have
daughters
anyone
berer well he was young enough
someone I'm more of a Ben Stein guy like
the
mature someone by the way also uploaded
a fake link to our story that redirected
to a a porn site just to be clear um and
later that same link redirected to a
fake Rumble site that looped our
starting soon card uh nonstop and there
has unsurprisingly been a media blackout
on the story completely zero coverage we
did expect that the only way for stories
like this to get any traction is if you
become the distribution you out there uh
and we'll talk about this more mug Club
um not only supporting but uh you know
taking part in the mug Club Army
especially if you have daughters sisters
mothers some of you might have been born
in a WF test tube I have no idea but uh
we'll talk about it more a little bit L
did I miss anything there Gerald no I
think you've covered it we we do have
additional information like there
there's always more to this but we're
again we're holding some of these things
back you have all of the relevant
information like we're not holding any
back anything back that's material it's
just like further proof for us because
we've been working on this you know the
team has been working on it for for
quite a while yeah make sure we get this
thing right we're going to get to the
New Hampshire primary which will be fun
because you know nick uh he doesn't he's
not a Nicki Haley fan no why not I don't
like her name oh it's it's the female
version of Nick before we get to hold on
a second has anyone where is Josh has
anyone seen Josh Josh firin by the way
who's been brought into yeah I was at a
screen test sorry about that what a
screen test I've been auditioning for
movies lately and uh yeah you got to
start somewhere no bites but uh I think
doing some some good work this is that's
unexpected what what film are you uh
screen testing for they're rebooting the
Terminator really yeah yeah yeah I'm
auditioning as the Terminator I actually
have the footage they let me have the
footage screen test yeah yeah to in all
right okay got it all right Josh
whenever you're ready okay
okay hi I'm a friend of Sarah Connor I
heard she was here can I see her please
no she's making a statement where is she
look it may be a while if you want to
wait there's a bench over there I'll be
back I'll get her a latte or something
she loves latte it's not in the script
oh you want one too big boy okay I don't
think you I don't think you know what
Terminator is no I nailed it they I
think it feel went good I feel good said
they're going to give me a call and oh
let me know about it so okay well you
then go check your voicemail yeah it be
a nice I'm sure you have some nice news
it'll be nice
yeah New Hampshire
primary how long's the
retainer they're not going to call okay
yeah yeah I don't think so all right
Terminator was a snuff
[Music]
film
just saying I was I go I know this isn't
because then I looked up the book
sapiens which he wrote right and boy I
can't wait to get into that one well you
should read a sequel
homo it's more of a prequel really that
is unbelievable a homo wrote a book
called
sapan that is true this guy he does have
the creepiest voice and uh yeah I
actually stayed up that's how old I am I
was reading that last night sapiens
well he's in the evolution of man
chasing the hunched man that's why he
goes
uppr come on don't spoil it he's got A
pedora and
P how else are we going to start using
tools I I know I'm like this guy's very
bright then I S he's banging another guy
thre it all away I think it scrambles
your brain either that or the poppers
that they take in the nightclubs do you
know that there's a that's like a
mediate brain damage is it really what
jalapeno bers yeah well that too if
you're talking about the TGI Fridays
that's immediate intestinal well you
know your your gut microbiome they say
directly affects your brain you know why
they taste so good fentanyl yes
yes I this coffee turn a vinegar I got
it here holy Christ well that's you know
like
Jesus turn coffee into vinegar that's
one of his lesser that's just how you
know Jesus was such a good guy how think
of how Petty I mean if any of us we were
dying like can I have a drink of water
like sure they give us a sponge of
vinegar and we had the power of the
Almighty you have any idea what I would
have done that whole place would have
looked like Kell's bachelor pad like
come on dad come on now not even The
Malt all right what movie uh no Kell is
Superman's dad the you know Kell or is
again I like
one that we can say for you've
all he has a book on that called
grow it's called no you evolve aera
that's what we'll call him
do doare as you all that'll be a good
one put that one come on let's do that
that's never mind I'll do it after I was
going into Dennis finina I know listen
here you homo I'm going to take
this pencil stab it in your eye you make
one more comment about my ass have a
cream soda
Sydney that's why I could never find a
woman from Chicago attractive I'm I
don't want to kiss Dennis
finina that's true to sever I love the
accent on guys yeah but on women no it
doesn't work oh my gosh you're so
hot that's not how women from Chicago
talk ni Nick you dirty Sicilian I want
you so
bad do me hard I feel like
Tina hard Fargo or what that's what it
is it's the same thing
[Music]
I
e out of a phone book
yes Arthur Anderson all right I'm done
it's true their accents you don't trust
their accents you don't trust like it
doesn't if if someone was coming from a
Chicago lab like all right look I found
I found the cure for SAR covid 2 you're
like no you didn't
no you absolutely did not f should put a
potato on my that's mancol should put a
put a potato on my forehead okay on my
forehead my
forehead in the South love I freaking
love I found the cure for cancer okay
you samity Sam you clearly did your
killer C killer T cell count is down to
four
melanoma you got a melanoma you got
melanoma that's just your hair ain't
going to look right found that cure for
diabetes diabetes it's going to be gone
hey hey guys Kim Jong-un is I'm telling
you he's here he's on the
roof like a dad at a certain point you
don't even check the closet for Monster
but he always says there's monsters so
all right okay I'm so tired that jolo's
bed is looking good to me
right it's about the size of a mattress
at a h I should have just let the coffee
spill on you it would have woken you oh
for the love of
Pete oh oh for the love of Pete Davids
sound like Ry santis hey look you take
your Buster Browns right out of right
out of this primary there
Buckaroo all right so Tuesday which was
yesterday today we are
Wednesday Wednesday being the day of
today's broadcast today being the day
that is Wednesday uh and you can by the
way hit the like button or Rumble smash
that if you want to right now just so
the algorithm certainly wants you to
think that we're dead Donald Trump of
course did beat Nikki haly in the
Republican primary but there is
something here that a lot of people have
skimmed over you say how did Nikki Haley
get any vote and that's a valid question
um and that's also what I think is the
most important Dynamic here this is not
about the Republican base or the
conservative base
deciding there's put it this way there's
no one in the country going Trump Haley
Trump right Haley it's not a thing
they're not H Israel
yes I don't know I don't know on the
fence I'm I'm undecided Frank luns in
your toue and shitty sneakers I'm
undecided is he still around big Frank
hands up if you
uh hands up if you know what an actual
focus group looks like all right let's
show a clip CBS News projects projects
Donald Trump will be the winner of the
New Hampshire Republican primary it's
the first time a Republican primary
candidate not technically an incumbent
has won both Iowa and New Hampshire
1976 projected WI the pain as the front
runner he's projected to be awarded at
least 12 delegates as a consolation
prize Nikki Haley will get at least nine
to be clear um we
project we projected that um at the like
always that's there was no point at
which we projected anything else and I
got mad at the Fox News decision that
right for calling Arizona too early so I
felt like oh am I being a hypocrite no
no no we we we
projected sure for Trump for Trump
always yes so this also about Trump got
54% it's it's broken some records Trump
got the most votes ever for a Republican
and just because it's hilarious um let's
show this clip of Donald Trump chiting
Nikki Haley as quote an impostor who the
hell was the impostor that went up on
the stage before and like claimed a
victory she did very poorly actually she
had to win the governor said she's going
to win she's going to win she's going to
win then she she failed badly I remember
I sort of had the same feeling I'm up
and I'm watching and I said she's taking
a Victory lap and we we beat her so
badly she was but Ron beat her also you
know Ron came in second and he left she
came in third and she's still hanging
around I didn't know that who's this
impastor said she won what is that is
that what is that what
do
he goes we kick and he stopped himself
he was going to be like we kicked her
you know what he's to say sh look Shone
needs to grab her by the and throw her
out
yes so by Nikki Haley was actually
impressed with her own performance and
she's going on we have exclusive footage
of Nikki H uh Nikki Haley celebrating
second
[Music]
place
sorry hey hey research team that was
Char
dish let's show the actual footage that
we do have from her campaign
headquarters
[Music]
yeah
all right so this is an important
Dynamic here my question to you is what
is your main takeaway from these
primaries aside from the fact that it's
obviously going to be Donald Trump right
uh some people call him former president
some people call him sitting president
Trump I call him I call him president
Trump yeah just to be clear that's fair
yeah and you respect the office former
Vice President Biden we really haven't
talked about former Vice President Biden
much because he's dead
so behind the boiler in the
basement hi somebody's wearing a Biden
suit a m set in and nobody realizes it
drink the
insure I take
it Carnation Instant bre all
right we're just going to continue
naming dated meal replacements now
here's the thing Nikki Haley did get
some votes and you're saying how good
here's how you have to understand that
in the state right uh unaffiliated
voters can vote so the big difference
here the importance to see and this is
how people like in the past I should say
uh like Mitch McConnell like Lindsay
like Mitt Romney ended up being
Representatives um there are ways to
gain the system and I'm not talking
about uh voting machine being created by
the ghost of Chavez okay I'm talking
about Foul Play that has taken place you
know like in the election that Stacy
Abrams claimed uh she won so claims
Donald Trump cleaned up not even that's
right that's right she still claims uh
with registered Republicans it wasn't
even close Haley only one with Democrats
and independents so with registered
Republicans that's 51% of Voters Trump
won 74 to 25 now with independent uh
voters they make up 43% of the voters
Trump only got 38% and Haley got 60%
then with Democrats who only made up 6%
of the V voters gr granted they should
make up no voters in a Republican
primary Trump got 5% and Haley got 88%
now I know you're saying hey hold on a
second how relevant is that what I want
you to keep in mind is that combined the
the independent and Democrat voters
right it's pretty much half of the
voting here now if you can vote
unaffiliated and you see the numbers
with the Republican voters or the
registered Republicans you obviously
would know that half of these people
have no business voting in the primary
at all and they have a and the question
becomes why do they have a vested
interest in Nikki Haley winning any sort
of primary State here's a New Hampshire
voter explaining exactly why how uh and
when they will continue to vote for
Haley Nikki Haley and why did you vote
for Nikki Haley uh it's a vote against
Trump I think it would be better to have
her against Biden in the uh elections
then yeah it would be Trump and her do
you consider yourself generally
independent Republican or Democrat uh
Democrat so when you Undeclared you
voted for Nikki Haley if it was Nikki
Haley against Joe Biden in a general
election who are you voting for Joe
Biden what is ah
that's the Haley contingency yes great
and then people say why oh look all all
the Trump tards you just want to say
establishment well said well
said wasn't even our question it was CNN
and of course Donald Trump and Haley
they seem to be at odds with each other
um some people suspect this you know
because there's political theater
they're actually just gearing up to
release their new album which yeah look
that's just I don't know if that's come
on I love that that's a good one back
check it she's a little bit rock
and
roll I've got you
they say don't pay the rent
that's what they say they say love
doesn't pay the that being a won't
pay the rent I would never say that but
I've got you that's what they say
I got that down a lot of people say that
Nick a lot of people say
God damn it
I can't even come close to them I can do
Jimmy Carter I can do the guy that died
on the porch drank a lemonade president
uh mck who the was that um mckenley
mckenley was assassinated yeah mckenley
shot you got a killer
McKinley no who's the guy that lemonade
and died remember uh no I don't remember
what is the story someone control room
ler this is an important Dynamic too
Donald Trump now still leads the
national average right he's uh beating
uh Joe Biden in a general by 2.9% this
is uh particularly notable when you
contrast it with the same time in 2020
in this election at the same stage in
the election Biden was up by four points
yeah so Donald Trump being up at all is
like it's seven point swing can I play
devil's advocate here though yes devil
just man of cloth jumped all over that
devil I'm just distracted because you
said Devil's Advocate and I was thinking
of that charlot that char charl yeah she
had that baby fat still oh yummy yummy
SP okay but play Devil's Advocate uh I
forgot what I was going to say really
you were thinking of your sister no what
was she's your sister about
Trum about Trump being up a couple of
point I want to get excited but that
almost sounds bad when you consider who
he's running against oh he's beating a
dead guy by two points you see what I'm
saying he should be that's how up
and I think how rigged all this is
it's all fake like the said somebody
wrote this story um I'm just saying he
should be up if in a semi-perfect world
the fact that they have to admit it at
all though means it's probably that's
true but I'm just saying in a seminormal
state of mind this country he'd be up by
I mean considering what Biden has done
which is zero he should be up by 38
points you would think so I I understand
I understand how I also don't want
people to be I was going to say like
what we've seen in the data is that this
margin tends to in the past it's
narrowed mean meaning Biden's lead
narrowed down right so what we're seeing
right now is that that lead doesn't
exist in the first place and if the
movement continues like it did in the
past Trump's lead will grow it won't
because uh we know how they play dirty
something's coming up well they played
dirty but if there is a certain point
where it's insurmountable but I do
appreciate you Playing devil's at but
still that's wrong she's my
sister so there are not enough people
who have seen that film great movie
you'll understand great movie come on
she's good-looking she's your sister no
I used to I used to jog around that
track
oh really in Central Park where the they
were the demons yeah the demons would
grab those guys yeah I that's but by the
way and I'm sorry I'm going off book but
it's a weird film if you don't know what
you're in for it's Devil's Advocate and
you're like oh this is a court drama n
and you're like no wait this is actually
about he's the devil yeah he's the
actual and then it becomes a
supernatural thing and it's it's all
it's not my favorite but the point is I
went in thinking this was going to be
like you know like the jury or the
verdict no you're right me too all of a
sudden alos got fir coming out of his
open like what am he's farting Flames I
this isn't a normal I didn't know that
how are they going to tie this in yeah
exactly who wrote this I was way off all
right so back to the New Hampshire
primary I guess uh January 22nd there
was a Harvard Harris poll and this is
also important because you look at this
primary you go okay well the
independence again these are
Independents who are Democrats because
they're unaffiliated yeah in a national
election Independents actually help
Donald Trump uh they increase his lead
over Biden so in a two-way race okay
Donald Trump 48 Biden 41 in a three-way
race Donald Trump 41 Biden 33 with RFK
Jr 18% so I don't want you to be
defeated us and say well this just means
that obviously unaffiliated or
independent voters that's going to harm
Donald Trump no as a matter of fact if
we have a third party candidate that
would help him more these are not
representative at all of independent
voters these are Democrat plants as you
just saw so New Hampshire is not
representing resentative of the rest of
the United States with their Franco
American Heritage New Hampshire no come
on yeah second primary you deserve it
New Hampshire yeah live free of vote for
Biden
right Fricks um and by the way this is
also pretty funny just because you know
I I like this he's already claiming
Victory because the next states are
going to be Nevada and then South
Carolina which of course Nikki Haley
will lose and that's going to be
embarrassing it'll be her home state I'm
sure she'll say it's a shot I'm sure
it's because she will say it's ovaries
now Donald Trump is claiming Victory
already in the upcoming or claimed it
Nevada Primary next week it's Nevada
Nevada next week it's Nevada it's not
South Carolina we love South Carolina
but next week it's Nevada oh God love
this and I'm pleased to announce we just
won
Nevada oh my
God I guarantee you right now the media
is coming out Donald Trump has admitted
to ringing the primary in Nevada okay
exactly right we'll do a thing on mental
Warfare it's like when uh uh Arnold uh
in that Pumping Iron documentary luo's
parents for the Mr Olympia he's like and
I you know I told your parents better
luck next to you that I already won the
Mr and poor LNO he just like got to
train
hor it's really uncomfortable watching
was a de guy like oh got to be got
Dr he talks like that that's exactly how
talk don't I ran into an airport you
wouldn't said it to his face no I did
well now he talks different I would I
would Incredible Hulk he would that's
all the steroids go I want to be the
Hulk too I'm the Hulk all right what a
monster though you got a better voice
out of it yeah all
right but that's what he did Arnold said
I already won it yeah and you could just
see it defeat L fno they did him dirty
in that Pumping Iron film it was all
fake and it was it was a hit job Arnold
is basically a sociopath now that being
said Haley it seems to be confident uh
that she can win South Carolina speaking
of soop this race is far far from over
there's are dozens of States left to go
I got tons of states to
lose why is she in a wet
suit and the next one is my sweet state
of South Carolina yes she's likeable
she's a li they will be stunned to find
out that Scuba Steve is amongst them
what the
evening gown you lost I have not
yet begun to lose who are you wearing
doesn't
matter I want to know I want to know who
are you wearing so they can get all the
publicity from your fantastic
performance who are you
wearing Balenciaga let's give them a
call I'm sure they're thrilled with
their decision it's called last
place
apparel you are broke
now he is destroying her in the South
Carolina polls 62 to 25 in her home
state is that right is this the domestic
battery you spoke up oh my God what a
beat him and everyone has endorsed him
by the way everyone has endorsed him in
South Carolina so this idea this is
where you need to know there is no
reason for her to be in this race no one
wants her in this race except for
Democrat voters where they can claim to
be unaffiliated and there are some
people who want to do harm to Donald
Trump the Democrat Party and the
Republican establishment are one and the
same but she wants you to believe that
no no no the reason I'm staying in is
because it's my home state is and I can
win it so we're going to make hold that
thought because I
I need to make a bold prediction here
and for this we actually rolled out our
company's
ultar wish is
granted the implication is she'll lose
South Carolina yes
Nick your head was huge I know I know it
moved kind of weird d it looked like a
mongloid trying to get a prediction
you'll be wearing a helmet in two weeks
what
um what was I going to say
I asked you to hold the no Hillary
uh Hillary what the the
IND uh Nick maybe she's playing I think
she's playing you know her her book
first of all speaking fees is GNA go up
the longest she stays in Book price all
that book sales and maybe she thinks
she's having a wet dream about VP which
we know it's not going to happen but
she's you know I mean she's doing this
for herself hence the wets suit yes
hence the wets suit I think she's never
going to Donald Trump would never bring
on as VP person stab in the back I know
you had some interesting predictions for
VP who yes I I again long shot I I want
V okay all right I want VC I've been
saying that forever Jim Brewer tried to
talk me out of it I don't know why uh
but uh my my long shot is but I I don't
know maybe not such a long shot Elise
stefanic oh yeah Elise stefanic the the
the woman in New York that made an ass
of Claudine gay and everybody else and
um she had always been touting how much
like every time I saw clips of her even
before the Harvard garbage she was
always defending Trump and his policies
and you know that goes a long way with
Mr Trump yeah well you know what that's
interesting I think I think some people
are thinking maybe Carrie Lake who will
have on the show tomorrow um that would
be great too it would be fun but again I
don't know if she really helps wi
Arizona uh don't they like her out there
well they they do she got she she
definitely got the old screw job there
with her her election um and I think it
could still be someone like a Tim Scott
but hey please no send your prediction
there uh below who you think please no
come on now you know what people will
say I know what I'm going to say you
know what people will say about saying
I'm a people um like I said about Tim
Scott nice guy the best black people are
not boring he's
boring black black people are not boring
they found a boring and he's a great guy
he's a true conservative he's got Mr
Ed's teeth I can't look at that ship for
the next every time I want to see him on
I throw my carrot yeah anybody Qui did
the you related to this guy I was
thinking of trying how to land this
plane before we go to Mud Club and then
the carrot thing and I was like all
right yeah Segways of a kid makes sense
or the guy who invented them who Dr Who
drove a Segway off a cliff that's how he
died did you know that the guy who
invented the segue died by segwaying off
a cliff on purpose or accident no he was
testing the off he was testing the
offroad testing the cliffing
capability's no footage did you not know
this I did not know this why would you
do that's got to make your day that is
one of the funnest facts ever I hope he
landed on rocks those things are
stupid I I can somebody explain have you
guys seen this I don't they have it in
Dallas some kid goes by my house every
day it's one wheel oh yes yes and he's
doing I'm not exaggerating he's doing at
least no even more than 30 3540 yeah and
and he's leaning forward if he so much
as hits a wet leave he's going to be
Steven Hawk it in 3 seconds kind of a
big I don't was fun while it lasted how
do you stop it like at a red light I
seriously I've been how you lean there's
like a gyroscope in it oh that's that's
that's that's good yeah exactly going to
busy intersection you got a Lane right
exactly that's what you said about
rollerblades too Nick right the love of
yes well I mean they're both pretty gay
so just to close this to give you some
context Nikki
Haley what one of us is in deep trouble
because the only time in modern history
that a candidate has lost their home
state uh in I should say in a in a
primary uh and become president was
1968 and that was Nixon right me just
say this there you go about that yes
exactly I got nothing to say go back to
stepen look I like she's I'll say this
so Nixon lost to also a
Californian but Nikki Haley is no tricky
dick she's really more look I would
never say this but people have told me
she's not she's no tricky dick she's an
un tricky is what they
say she's no tricky
Nicki that's what he said he does the
Nixon not and it's quite you know he
says he's not a crook I believe him
unlike Nikki Haley who I don't believe
frankly cuz she's a liar old that's what
people say and I say don't say that they
say it's true so don't say we're going
to discuss more of this and also we have
some audio as it relates to um the the
car Lake story I was about to say Nikki
Haley the other car Lake story where um
she made claims I think she's but now
it's it's she made the claims and now
there are receip than the claims that
someone tried to bribe her to stay out
of 2024 Arizona set it race and we're
going to Playa something no no
what all right look it's going to be a
lot of fun because Nick is in a Nick is
in a mood uh if you're watching hit that
button join mug Club there's no more
investigative journalism without you
supporting it anyway and we're going to
go on for another 45 minutes to an hour
and discuss car Lake and play bad movie
lines if you're watching on YouTube I
don't know what your problem is thank
you very much Rumble YouTube piss
[Applause]
off